metal gear solid 5 has been an absolute
dream to play this past week and not
just because of its wonderful action and
tactical gameplay but because of the
fantastic water cooler conversations
that it provides
did you see the thing i did oh my gosh
[Music]
away from story spoilers the sheer
amount of interesting moments that this
game creates is incredible crazy
combinations of events and strategies
that emerge from within the game's rules
and mechanisms and we have a word for
the process by which these moments are
created it's known as emergent gameplay
now we hear this term thrown around
quite a lot certain games and developers
are famous for utilizing it but what
exactly does it mean what is emergent
gameplay is it glitches is it
discovering you could do something that
you didn't know you could do are these
moments intended by the designer or are
they unintentional flukes that gamers
discover by themselves today on the
point we explore the wonderful world of
emergent gameplay and explain how it's
forever changed what we love and expect
from video games
[Music]
so
okay first things first when it comes to
the gaming language we don't really have
a grasp of what emerging gameplay means
it comes up quite a lot but it's
difficult to define and the reason for
this is because it actually refers to
two largely different phenomena so allow
me to explain rather generally emerging
gameplay is what happens when these
simple rules and mechanisms of the game
are combined together to create
unexpected results and this happens in
two forms intentional emergence and
unintentional emergence
intentional emerging gameplay occurs
when a game gives you a set of tools and
mechanisms and allows you the player to
find creative means of utilizing them to
complete the objective games like metal
gear solid and deus ex provide accurate
simple examples of this these games give
you a defined goal say infiltrate a base
or capture a hostage and then they
provide you with a bunch of tools and
methods to do so the emergence happens
when the game successfully reacts to you
manipulating the game's rules to achieve
that goal like using a cardboard box to
slide down a hill and knock over some
enemies using hacking skills to turn a
robot against its master or shooting a
love arrow at an otherwise angry cthulhu
to create a friendly mount warren
specter referred to emerging gameplay as
engines of perpetual novelty and we do
often find that games that employ
emerging gameplay are often really fun
to replay over and over and encourage
you to explore that novelty for instance
in bioshock luring an enemy into a
puddle and then using your electro bolt
on the water to shock them more
vigorously or using a supply crate drop
in phantom pain to crush an unwitting
enemy emergence also exists in most
role-playing games tabletop d and d
games or their video game equivalents
like ultima or less traditionally system
shock 2 where small decisions made early
on say adopting a certain set of skills
or deciding to pick up a specific item
or not could result in an entirely new
way of completing a mission later on
because of the breadth of this term some
moments certainly seem more emergent
than others but we generally appreciate
that with all intentional emergence the
designers designed the game with the
intention of you discovering these
moments however this is not the case for
the second type of mergers we're going
to talk about today unintentional
emergence this is when gamers beat them
as individuals or groups or online
communities find mechanical glitches in
games or create entirely new ways of
playing games that the developers never
intended one of the most obvious
versions of this is speedrunning entire
communities are players whose win
condition has nothing to do with the
goals set by the designer it also comes
up in the form of glitches sequence
breaking in metroid or using wall mines
to clamber up walls and deus ex a
wonderfully emergent game in itself but
you have to admit they probably didn't
intend that one it can also mean
entirely new ways of playing games jump
maps and counter-strike is another
example machine animation or the mario
kart frat game don't drink and drive
where you have to finish a beer while
trying to beat your friends at mario
kart the rug being that nobody is
allowed to drink and drive at the same
time all of these are new ways of
playing these games that the developers
hadn't aimed for you've probably created
some unintentional emergency yourself
what i made with my friend was called
fifa death ball i played fifa a lot but
some of my friends weren't that great at
scoring goals but what they were good at
was performing dirty tackles and getting
their players sent off so we fashioned
the game where a red card had the same
value as a goal so instead of scoring
you could get yourself a goal by
tackling the [__] out of the other
team's center forward fifa death ball
was our game and it was an unintentional
emergence from the core mechanics of
fifa09 and a beautiful thing i came
across while doing research for this
episode was that somebody on the
emergent gameplay subreddit had also
invented the same unintentionally
emergent game they called it rather
simply the fifa red card game and
deathball has a better ring to it
sometimes designers invent their own
intentional emergence achievements and
trophies are a good example of this or
the known chomsky run where you carry a
garden gnome through half-life episode 2
or left 4 dead 2. that would have been
unintentional emergent gameplay if
gamers had come up with it themselves
but it wasn't because valve had an
achievement for it meaning it was an
intentional way of playing the game
albeit a strange and frustrating one for
me these moments of unintentional
emergence are fun sidebars that you can
apply to most games but intentional
emergent gameplay when developers
actually create worlds which react to
your clever ideas these are a thing to
be cherished
most games are about getting the high
score unlocking all the stuff killing
all the dudes these games reward you for
being skillful emerging gameplay rewards
you for being clever like far cry 2 in
the midst of a battle when your gun
falls apart and the grass around you is
catching fire and suddenly you need to
eject your malaria meds you don't just
hit restart like you would in another
fps you embrace the chaos you think on
your feet and when you come up with a
solution it feels far more satisfying
than any test the game could have
explicitly given you it feels like
you're a moment and your solution and
that's the power of emerging gameplay
and that's a thing of beauty in metal
gear solid 5 the phantom pain like deus
ex and thief you're encouraged to find
creative solutions to invading bases and
rescuing or killing certain targets like
far cry 2 and bioshock it rewards you
for adapting in fire fights and coming
up with creative solutions to combat
problems last tuesday night while
writing this very script i had one such
moment
while infiltrating a base i was spotted
by two guards and forced to tranq them
then i noticed the third guard was
approaching so i threw the first guy off
a small cliff and picked up the second
to hide the body i've run too far away
with this guy on my shoulder by the time
i notice but the third soldier wanders
over to the cliff sees his body and goes
down to wake him up
i sprint as fast as i can to try and
stop him before he wakes his friend and
then they're too far away from me to
reflexive before they alert the entire
base but by the time i get to the cliff
he's already waking his friend so in
that instant i do the only thing i can
think of
a decade ago many game designers said
that the future of game design was in
emerging gameplay and we're already
seeing evolutions on that model eve
online's politics and economy for
instance these are both intentional and
unintentional
but one thing is for sure these games
are hard to make not necessarily in
terms of cost time and people power but
in terms of thought
emergent systems are difficult to design
which is why they require talented
designers to create them they take risk
care and love but when they work out
they result in games we continue to talk
about decades later hideo kojima is one
such developer through the metal gear
solid franchise he has evolved his own
particular style of emerging gameplay
into the wonderfully crazy sandbox we've
gotten to enjoy these past two weeks and
here's the thing we're becoming
increasingly thirsty for more
when we sit back and take a look at the
wonderful games we've enjoyed in 2015 we
often celebrate open world design
immersive hd worlds and believable
stories as the reason these games are so
much fun to play but what if the secret
sauce is actually something else
consider metal gear solid 5 the witcher
3 with its emergent narrative shadow of
mordor's nemesis system the upcoming
fallout 4. these are emergent systems
which aren't just about completing a
task these are games that encourage you
to complete tasks in the way you see fit
they reward experimentation and take
your actions into consideration
compare these two recent less popular
open world games watchdogs assassin's
creed unity arkham knight maybe even mad
max they're similar in terms of the open
world freedom they allow many of these
games have decent combat and large
beautiful worlds but ultimately everyone
plays these games missions in the same
linear way or at least the type of
variety they employ has become
commonplace i mean when exactly was the
last time assassin's creed required any
of us to think on our feet in fact many
of these games do a lot more reminding
you of how exactly to complete the
mission than encouraging you to explore
the gameplay yourself now this doesn't
make them bad games many of these games
have great combat and fun environments
to explore but in a world with phantom
pain and the witcher 3 this type of
linear checkbox gameplay is becoming
less and less interesting
[Music]
we all have different tastes as gamers
but a well-constructed emergent system
is about as close as you can get to a
universally delicious menu option and
metal gear solid 5 the phantom pain is a
fantastic example of just how fun and
engaging these emergent systems can be
but what do you think do you like
emergent systems what emergent stories
do you have to tell i'd love to hear
your thoughts hit me up at daniel dwyer
on twitter or stick your thoughts in the
comment box below
yeah that was always gonna happen
and we'll see you guys in two weeks for
another episode of the point exploring
the culture and influence of one of my
favorite games of all time see you then
[Music]
you